[Música]
este castillo de estilo renacentista
probablemente habría permanecido en el
anonimato si no hubiera sido el hogar de
la esposa secreta del rey luis 14
mandando un manto no su verdadero nombre
era françoise núñez una mujer de origen
modesto a la que se le suele comparar
con ceniciento
[Música]
no suelta dios venía de françois se
convertirá en tutora de los bastardos de
louis 14 y manden spam así es cómo
conoció a louis 14 614 le pagó un
salario por este servicio es gracias a
este salario que comprara el castillo y
entonces poco a poco luis 14 se
enamorara de madam de monte no es la
verdadera historia de amor
he visto gente
el rey sol se casó con ella y
permanecieron casados durante más de 30
años tiempo durante el cual sufrió
numerosas transformaciones
esta torre cuadrada del siglo 17 estaba
destinado originalmente a vigilar el río
y proteger el lugar de los ataques pero
comandando montó no perdió su función de
defensa y se transformó gradualmente en
un lugar de residencia
en el ciclo 17 cuando mandé monte no
compro el castillo hizo las ventas aquí
en la torre cuadrada ya que era una
torre defensiva por supuesto en la edad
media no habían aberturas como ésta y
man the mountain ahora instalará
aposentos para sus invitados en la torre
cuadrada sociedad beach
están actualmente cerrados al público
por razones de seguridad
el señor render último propietario
privado del castillo recuerda el estado
de deterioro cuando su esposa lo heredó
después de la segunda guerra mundial
a
los bombardeos de 1945 y los anteriores
habían dejado el castillo prácticamente
sin techo ni ventanas muchos techos se
habían derrumbado
la mayor parte de las puertas interiores
fueron voladas sin embargo éramos
jóvenes y probablemente un poco
inconscientes así que asumimos el
proyecto y empezamos en el 53
dedicaron su vida a restaurar el
castillo para devolverle su antiguo
esplendor hasta el punto de que hoy en
día el lugar acoge a decenas de miles de
visitantes cada año
ah
y les digo una edu
si escucho la palabra una educadora que
es una educadora y programa de esta
clase de primaria es la educación del
siglo 17 cada tema requiere al menos dos
meses de preparación con herramientas
hechas a la medida nos adaptamos mucho
con las fotografías las representaciones
de época para que puedan establecer el
vínculo entre el hoy y el ayer y
entonces lleguen a un lugar tan mágico
un castillo siempre es un sueño están
muy contentos de poder descubrirlo de
una manera diferente a las visitas
tradicional es cierto que les gustan las
visitas niños
en 10 años el número de visitantes se ha
cuadruplicado en un monte un hombre no
sin crear algunos problemas
el paso de los visitantes y las
vibraciones debilitan ciertas obras para
proteger mejor las colecciones como
estos dos mil doscientos libros el
castillo forma parte de un programa
europeo de conservación preventiva desde
2018 una 10 expert tenemos expertos que
vienen a establecer el riesgo de
deterioro por la eliminación por el
calor por el hecho de que uno de los dos
lados del castillo están más cerca del
oro y por lo tanto tiene altos niveles
de humedad
a parte de las colecciones el aspecto
más exigente del recinto es el jardín
francés
reconstruido a partir de los diseños del
famoso jardinero en otro hay que saber
qué hicieron planos del jardín estaban
en la bibliothèque nationale de france
en realidad nunca se había construido
así que en 2013 decidimos crear este
jardín con cuerda e hilo como en los
tiempos del heno que exactamente igual
el jardín ha sido completamente
reconstruido con los métodos de la época
y requiere una atención constante se
necesitan cuatro jardineros para podar
los 12.000 bosques y los cerca de 60
topiarios
lo importante es que podamos con tijeras
de mano tijeras manuales verdad así que
si se quiere conseguir un corte limpio
en una planta se poda siempre con
tijeras de mano y se desarrollan y mucho
menos enfermedades en contraste con un
jardín formal clásico este se llena de
flores en primavera siempre con un toque
de azul nada de montes no siempre decía
si pudiera habría cubierto el castillo
de azul así que en un guiño magda de
monte siempre plantó azul a lo largo del
río aquí ponemos nomeolvides azules que
se plantan aquí plantamos también salvia
mística azul así que siempre hay un
color azul para matando mundo
cada año se plantan 15.000 tulipanes
para que florezcan en primavera y formen
un conjunto de colores en igual un
evento anual que recibe el dulce nombre
de tula para una forma poética de
revivir la leyenda del castillo de la
esposa secreta del rey sol
[Música]